greetings Bill Nye here these are my
favorite snacks
[Music]
so what happens these things come flying
in
Lifesavers this is a go-to product
people now when I was young Lifesavers
came in a roll but I think the mothers
of the world have cracked down on the
potentially unhygienic presentation of a
traditional roll of lightsabers got it
I do it really do you have a chainsaw or
something I'm going to start with the
Cherry
pretty great so everybody your sense of
smell
is certainly the primary sense in
evolution as far as we can tell here on
Earth all of us living things we all had
a common ancestor estimated about 3.7
billion years ago and as these organisms
interacted and reproduced and got more
complex the sense of smell for mobile
organisms worms
my old boss
was a fundamental sense and this is at
the base of your brain what Carl Sagan
would call the reptile brain when you
taste a candy like this Exquisite
Lifesaver it's getting you deep in your
brain man if we can go back in time hang
out with OGG the cave guy oh jet the
cave woman and show them Life Savers
they'd be like wow man men from the
future this rocks how long do I have to
wait well if you're a cave guy in
northern France I guess like 17 000
years or something I'm gonna just
swallow the last bit you guys because
we're working
we're working eating snacks on
television
next up we have yogurt I'm a fan of the
wee yogurt which is real French yogurt
made with milk very fond of vanilla and
when it comes to vanilla you just go
maybe the universe has a plan the
universe is not out to get us maybe the
universe really is benevolent
[Music]
so right there what I recommend is you
guys edit in the broken glass cat
Screech so when I take this off I go
like that
yeah
shh really funny yogurt is produced by
living things you're eating live culture
what
and look I'm fine we have more bacteria
in our guts than there are people on
Earth each of us and we get those
bacteria by hanging out with our parents
smooching with our mom and the in-laws
and these bacteria get in you and then
we need those bacteria to digest our
food without them we we couldn't be here
[Music]
I'm telling them
it's pretty great
Lay's classic potato chips people what
are the two things we want in life salt
and fat that's it right there man
there's no preservatives there's no
extra industrially produced flavors
there's potatoes oil and salt that's a
whole thing genius and I know you're out
there and you want barbecue flavor you
want jalapeno you want sour cream and
onion but fundamentally potato salt the
oil it's cooked in you can't beat it you
can't beat it people have tried to beat
it can't beat it
huh oh man sunchip says for some of you
may know was the official chip of the
Bill Nye the Science Guy show
I'm kidding there was there was no
official chip of the bill Nyes we
couldn't make that deal how about that
anyway to me his sonship is genius the
sonship is the right mixture of the
various grains and a little bit of salt
now I understand there's a lot of
sonship people who want the cheese
flavor well I mean okay more for me by
the way they never run out of the cheese
flavor do they but this one disappears
why because it's the best the best
I've heard of this thing called the
Bliss point do you have any perspective
on that
greetings everyone Bill Nye here
I've been asked to provide perspective
on why or how food Mass producers get to
the Bliss Point what do you think they
do they test it they have people eat
them they have a zillion people eat them
and these are professionals they have
chefs yes Sun ships were created by
chefs by deep fat frying pros and they
test different combinations different
amounts of salt they test the color of
the packaging and and then they come up
with the perfect chip
perfect sonship
yes
you can hope and you can dream life
doesn't get much better than popcorn
with salt so I popped a popcorn on the
stove top on the stove top doesn't don't
you need a pot yeah you need a pot for
that and your stove that gets hot and
we're here in the developed world I have
both of those things as a popcorn
Enthusiast for me it's a Venn diagram in
the middle Orville Redenbacher not
Orville Redenbacher it's logic problem
olive oil
on the stove top and then salt and
that's all I do what about cheese
okay yeah okay I enjoy it all but for me
at home Orville Redenbacher olive oil
salt that's it it's a whole deal there
was a whole industry for about 10 years
of the air popper the air popper was
going to take over the world the heat
doesn't get into the kernel fast enough
the oil makes the kernel pop fast enough
to get the satisfying Orville
Redenbacher with salt combo that is
as far as I can tell completely
unbeatable
so what about a healthy snack well I
tell you guys eat a lot of dried fruit
you've all had plums right well Plum is
becomes a prune I'm really good if you
know the um the Cowardly Lion he asked
the musical question what puts the ape
in apricot
courage
try it people they're delicious by the
way for you fiber Buffs prunes or plums
have some extraordinary over-the-top
amount of fiber considering how small
each prune is it's amazing don't take my
word for it try it
[Music]
oh people people
pecan sandies oh my goodness
goodness that's what I'm talking about
these ordinary uh I know many of you out
there enjoy a little glass of Port
understandable
port with a pecan Sandy
[Music]
it's fit for royalty I'm just saying now
during the day let's say you're at the
beach and I'm not joking and you're
enjoying a ice cold bottle of water
with a pecan Sandy and the Sea Breeze
[Music]
I just think they're excellent
thanks for watching happy snacking to
you the end is nine with Bill Nye and
there's six episodes where we end the
world I get killed
six different ways and we show how we
could prepare and mitigate these
disasters with
with science Turn It Up loud everybody
it was great you guys it was odd it was
hard
[Music]